we are now in this war we're all in it
all the way every single man woman and
child is a partner the most tremendous
undertaking of our American history have
that deep permanent inner satisfaction
that comes from doing the best we know
how
not going to be a safe landing I got a
point
Steve
you've been a sleep cap for almost 70
years
we're here with a mission sir kind of
getting back in the world trying to save
it
mostly the intelligence community
doesn't believe he exists the ones that
do call him the Winter Soldier
lucky Wells Bucky
he's credited with over two dozen
assassinations in the last 50 years
wanted man and I'm planning on taking
you alive I know how much Bucky means
you stay out of this one please you only
make this worse you saying you'll arrest
me
captain you seem a little defensive paws
been a long day
sorry time
you know I wouldn't do the spider never
choice
but he's my friend
so was I
you gave me this mission this is how it
ends
you just started a war
you chose the wrong side
you